hello
i'm going to briefly talk about breeding
for resistance to biotic damage in
vegetable crops specifically tomato
probiotic challenges could be bacterial
diseases fungal or myc diseases viral
diseases or insects which cause direct
damage by feeding or indirect damage by
transmission of pathogens such as virus
to control crop damage while maximizing
reduction in chemical sprays one must
control each of the biotic stresses
currently controlled by that spray
the question
one example
why are fungicides used in the northeast
field tomato production
the answer to control three different
diseases late blight early blight and
septoria leaf spot
therefore to protect the crop and its
quality while reducing fungicidal sprays
one must breed for resistance to each of
these three diseases
we were able to do that using previously
identified late blight and early blight
resistances
we identified and mapped additional qtl
for septoria resistance
created markers for all of these qtls to
be able to select for each of them in
segregating populations
ultimately creating lines containing all
of these resistances
this approach quickly created the
desired lines
in well-adapted backgrounds
now to support the release and
utilization of these lines multi-year
regional trials by wonderful
collaborators in new york pennsylvania
north carolina virginia
and west virginia tested experimental
hybrids created using these new fungal
resistant lines
and the trial results supported a very
rapid commercializations of hybrids
created using them
most importantly
the combination of the resistances
achieved up to a 70 reduction in the
number of sprays per season with the
greatest reduction seen in the seasons
that were favorable to the diseases
now the project was expanded repeating
the process by adding resistances to two
bacterial diseases bacterial spot and
bacterial spec
now interestingly we accidentally
discovered a new early blight resistant
qtl
in the process of handling the bacterial
spot while bacterial spot qtls
and this
early blight qtl was also transferred to
the new lines for even better control of
that disease
the resulting lines
combining fungal and bacterial
resistances are now released and
experimental hybrids are in regional
trials so this process of co-targeting
all the diseases controlled by the
fungicide succeeded
we'll switch to a contrasting example
control of insects and insect
transmitted virus
now again we've got a question why are
pesticides heavily used on tomato crops
in warm climates the answer is control
of insects and insect transmitted virus
which are devastating
exacerbating the situation is that
insects and viruses can both have wide
host ranges so it's hard if not
impossible to eliminate them in your
environment
the pesticides are expensive lose their
efficacy
and have negative impacts on the
environment so a different method was
needed
we targeted acyl sugars which are insect
resistant compounds found in trichome
exudates in some wild solenaceous
species
the selenium pineally eye produces large
amounts you can see these droplets on
the trichomes
the exudate is about 95 ace of sugar
acyl sugars are effective against many
different species of insects so in this
case the resistance system itself has
considerable breadth of action
we're not having to transfer resistance
to each insect separately
where you're using one broad mechanism
to target several insects
the acyl sugars act on contact
with the insects
causing feeding and over position
deterrence
since insects must feed to transmit
virus
strongly reducing feeding could reduce
virus inoculation
the first tomatoes producing high levels
of acid sugar were
cu97fl and then from a series of sister
lines we chose cuo71026
now what is immediately obvious here is
that under heavy field pressure this was
in florida
there are over 100 110
um
flies per leaflet of unprotected tomato
however they're less than two
white fly per leaflet on most of the
acyl sugar lines
now all of these acyl sugar lines
produce the same form of basil sugar
which is quite different from its
pinellas parent
and among the different accessions of
panelia you'll find accessions that
produce different forms of basil sugar
so the question
comes up
which is important is a sugar level iso
sugar type or a combination
to examine this question
we isolated and purified acyl sugars
from four accessions of pinelli two from
the northern extent into the southern
extent of its range
and also from o71026
and then applying equal molar levels of
the
acyl sugars to an appropriate feeding
platform for each of the insects tested
we would ask the question
what is the impact and the differences
in the impacts of the different acel
sugars
well 071026 is an acyl sucrose with
branched chain fatty acids based on an
iso c5 platform 5 carbon
716 which was parental to
071026 and 1732 are southern accessions
of pinelli and they produce acyl
glucoses that are based on iso c4
um platform quite different
the northern range um accessions of
pinelli
these two
produce a 50 50 mix of acyl sucrose and
nasal glucose and have fatty acids that
are more similar to those in o7 1026
and you can see the response of in this
case western flower thrip to the acyl
sugars was quite different
if you just look across the side
horizontally here
about 2.5
milligrams per milliliter solution was
used
in this case could produce that degree
of control where you'd have to go up to
about five to get the same level control
with the southern accessions of pinelli
and all the way over to 16 or 17
milligrams per milliliter in order to
get similar control from 0.71026
so acyl sugar type definitely affects
the efficacy of the compound
this gives us the prediction that tomato
breeders can optimize as mediated
control of insects by increasing acell
sugar level
or control or both
so we needed a way to have tomato lines
producing acid sugars that were
different in level or type
first we identified the qtl which would
affect basil sugar level or type
then back cross them into
071026 to create this series of sister
lines
for example a qtl on chromosome 6 al6
almost doubles acid sugar level but the
acyl sugar is the same as that of o7126
and opposite qtl is fa5 which almost
blocks associated production producing a
line that is a wonderful control for the
other sister lines
fatty acid 2 fatty acid 7 or qtl that
either increase in the case of fatty
acid 2 or decrease the length of some of
the fatty acid side chains of the acyl
sugar and when combined increase acyl
sugar level 90 to 95 percent
and an addition of three or four qtl was
necessary to create an acyl glucose line
these lines were used by collaborating
entomologists and virologists to
determine the levels and types of acyl
sugars that best control different
important pests and their associated
transmitted virus
and i will just go in two examples
first is western flower threat which
transmits tomato spotted wild virus
if we look at over position
to determine the degree of deterrence
on the different lines you can see that
there is a great deal of opposition on
standard tomato and even on the line
that has blocked acyl sugar production
0.71026 and the other sister lines have
much lower levels of oval position with
some of the sister lines being
significantly lower than 0.71026
looking at
the um probability of inoculation from 0
to 100
you see it's very high in tomato and
071026 itself is not as good as would be
desired for controlling inoculation by
tomato spotted wilt virus but some of
the sister lines are quite good
similarly looking at silver leaf white
fly famicia which transmits tomato
yellow leaf girl virus
the first trials were field cage trials
with a few lines that raised acid sugar
level as you can see here
the qtl6 is also associated with an
increase in trichome density which no
doubt has some of the some of the reason
for the increased acyl sugar level
as you can see we had very high levels
of white fly
on the tomato control
but
it was strongly decreased in 0.71026
and significantly further reduced
in the sister lines with higher levels
of basal sugar so higher levels of basal
sugar
increase suppression deterrence of the
insects
in another series of tests looking at
tomato yellow leaf curl virus
transmission and inoculation into plants
by the solar leaf white plant
now this part of the slide is showing
the percent infection which gets very
high for tomato
but is lower for most of the different
tomato asosure lines tested
and significantly lower for some of them
in this case the researchers went one
step further and looked at acquisition
of tylcb by a
whitefly that initially was clean was
not carrying virus
and so we had some virus infected plans
of each type of each line
and what they were doing
was looking at whether or not the white
flies became voliferous acquired the 2i
lcd
and there were some acquiring it for any
line but they were lower for the acyl
sugar lines and significantly lower for
some
in that
series of experiments
there are more experiments going on with
these and other insects and insect
transmitted virus
now in order for this trait to be used
commercially it has to be used by the
seed companies in their breeding
ce071026n9 97fl could not be used by
seed companies because there's just too
much pinelli
dna in their genome and some of the
integrations are so large that they are
carrying
genes for negative plant or fruit traits
so in the past several years we've been
selecting for shorter forms of the
integrations and testing to
ascertain that they have retained their
acyl sugar qtl but have lost their
association with negative qtl that are
affecting plantar fruit type
we are now combining these short
integrations pyramiding them as it were
into final lines that should produce the
level and type of acid sugars needed to
control insect and
insect transmitted virus
these final lines will have genomes that
are only two to three percent pinelli
compared to 25 percent in cu 97fl and 12
in
c071026
substantially less wild species dna
which is why the plants are looking much
more
normal
the type of lines we are producing are
shown below there's a class a and a
class b that differ slightly with the
qtls on chromosome 3 but are otherwise
similar
thank you very much
and i will just leave it with this slide
showing wonderful collaboration by
entomologists and biologists at
different institutions
you